bonsoir à tous c'est un peu
impressionnant square au théâtre
d'habitude je fais court en première
année on est mieux dans l'amphi mais au
moins je les vois davantage là c'est que
je veux à personne
alors je vais cours en première année de
quoi en première année de médecine donc
on va parler de santé le gros avantage
en général quand on parle de santé
c'est que tout le monde écoute pour deux
raisons c'est qu'il ya une certitude
dans la vie c'est qu'on n'est qu'à un
moment on meurt qu'on est tous concernés
par la fin et que souvent entre les deux
il ya une case qui est la case
malheureusement maladie et qu'il est
rare de passer de la première à la
troisième case d'emblée et donc
forcément les gens m'écoutent
alors je me suis dit est-ce que je les
fais tomber dans les pommes tout de
suite quand leur montrant des images
atroces
je suis dit on va attendre ça pour la
fin donc ceux qui souvent un petit peu
anxieux
partez une minute avant la fin je
donnerai le top et on a commencé en
douceur
on va commencer en douceur et je vais
essayer de vous expliquer normalement si
ça marche la technologie pourquoi je
suis là
alors pourquoi je suis là si je vous
regarde de face vous pouvez vous dire à
ce qu'il ya à peu près la stature de
boris becker si je vous maître mot m
profil vous allez dire c'est forcément
pas parce qu'il a gagné à roland garros
effectivement c'est pas parce que j'ai
gagné roland garros que je suis là et
comme un invité ce soir mais pourtant
j'ai cru parce qu'il ya environ un an
j'ai reçu un petit peu comme nos amis
tennisman un grand grand cheikh a larger
par décence enlever le chiffre qui est
beaucoup plus petit que si jamais
j'avais gagné roland garros est ce chai
qui m'a été remis alors c'est en fait un
titre et pour ceux qui ont vu le teaser
de de cette présentation de ce soir le
maurice muller howard morris muller
c'est un vieux vieux vieux des cds liés
dans la castro chirurgien orthopédiste
que je suis aussi en fête et
il est décerné par une société qui
s'appelle chaos ce qu'est la société 2
international de chirurgie assistée par
ordinateur donc ça va être de ça dont on
va parler ce soir est la deuxième raison
pour laquelle je suis là c'est encore la
case 3 vous allez me dire c'est une
obsession chez lui c'est parce que j'ai
accepté de participer à cette conférence
et si j'ai accepté d'y participer c'est
suite à un événement funeste qui est la
disparition de david begg allez dire ça
y est un générateur et disent non à des
réputations un peu bizarre je n'en
parlerai tout à l'heure mais là c'est
une obsession de la castro alors
pourquoi david bowie david bowie la
chirurgie orthopédique roland garros le
check list une histoire de fou bat david
bowie est mort vous le savez tous pour
ceux qui savent pas assez long moment
surtout que depuis ce matin il est plus
européen et quand david bowie est mort
il ya quelqu'un qui est important dans
ma vie qui est mon professeur de piano
parce que quand je m'ennuie je cei
je me suis mis à 40 ans donc tu es pas
bon du tout va d'y aller c'est le moment
d'essayer de jouer space oddity alors
space oddity c'est un morceau
fantastique que je massacre mais
pourquoi c'est un des premiers messages
de la soirée c'est que si vous voulez
réussir dans ce que vous faites faut
persévérer
donc je continue depuis le mois de
janvier massacrées space oddity dans un
casque ce qui évite de massacrer ma
famille on est donc ce pays soviétique
quand on est trop mauvais on se dit
c'est tellement beau que je suis allé
sur youtube et je suis tombé sur un
homme fantastique que je connaissais pas
et j'ai découvert
chris hadfield
alors je vous laisse juste profiter de
seconde de space oddity non un peu plus
chris hadfield c'est un astronaute vous
l'aurez deviné qui quand il boit pas de
la bière joue de la guitare et il a joué
dans la station spatiale internationale
ce morceau que je cherchais
désespérément suite de la disparition de
david bowie alors j'ai que 20 minutes
donc on va arrêter je vous conseille
d'aller vous acheter une guitare ce
week-end et essayer de jouer ça dans
l'année dans la navette spatiale vous
dans votre cuisine
ce sera plus simple et donc chris
hadfield je me suis dit c'est un type
est absolument incroyable qui sait tout
faire et j'ai donc creusé qui était le
personnage toujours via nos outils
habituels de deux geeks on va dire dans
qt hub et je suis tombé sur les
conférences ted c'est comme ça que je
les ai découvertes et c'est pour ça que
quand on m'a dit est ce que voulait en
faire une j'ai forcément dit oui
alors on en écoute 30 secondes
non
ça m'a beaucoup plu je vous conseille
aussi la fin la conférence est juste
fantastique et nous explique comment il
est devenu aveugle dans l'espace et
comment il a géré la peur liée à ça et
je me suis dit en regardant ce donc
scellé hasardeux de flâner sur le web
que finalement dans la chirurgie
orthopédique on n'était pas très loin on
était aussi dans un environnement un
petit peu complexe et puis on avait
aussi des situations parfois un petit
peu bizarre à gérer qui vont de celui
qui est passé sous son bateau à celui
qui a été rattrapé par le cancer c'est
extrêmement variés extrêmement complexe
et vous verrez dans sa conférence is it
un de ses collègues astronautes et il
dit ceci dans l'espace en gros il n'y a
pas de problème suffisamment embêtant
pour qu'on puisse encore le rendre plus
grave et au bloc opératoire c'est un
petit peu pareil c'est à dire que c'est
complexe
puis parfois pendant ça devient encore
plus complexe et rarement ça va à la
casse 3 mais souvent dans la case de on
n'est pas au mieux et je me suis dit que
finalement il y avait peut-être une
analogie et le but retouches que je
voulais vous faire passer comme message
dans ce début d'intervention c'est que
soyez curieux
soyez pas forcément de génie mais soyez
curieux et vous arriverez à faire plein
de choses a croisé plein de choses à
croiser la musique à l'espace comme moi
je les fais vous allez le comprendre
petit à petit pour croiser un certain
nombre de choses qui font qu'aujourd'hui
où l'année dernière j'ai reçu ce gros
chèque
alors je vous dis il faut être curieux
la deuxième conférence que j'ai regardé
deux minutes après c'est celle là et je
me suis dit que finalement si elle en
faisait une je devais pouvoir aussi et
c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté
c'est une conférence de monica levinsky
vous la connaissez tous savoir qu'on ne
connaissait pas et en fait c'est surtout
c'est pas tant ce que raconte qu'elle va
nous intéresser c'est quand 97 98
quand elle était célèbre pour ses
exploits sportifs
moi j'étais juste ici sous le nuage
j'étais dans cette grande ville alors
pour ceux qui la reconnaissent il n'y a
rien à gagner
c'est philadelphie en fait il s'est
avéré que et c'est ça je voulais vous
transmettre c'est que j'ai commencé
petit comme un bon enfant de l'école
publique à nantes puis je suis arrivé à
brest alors j'avais aucun cas un gros
atavisme familial on va dire mon arrière
grand père tenait le moulin de telgruc
donc forcément ça attire et je suis
arrivé à brest donc je suis inscrit à du
bo
et puis à un moment je suis parti à
philadelphie donc en 97 et à
philadelphie ya un bond au dessus du bon
il ya une statue sur la statue c'est
benjamin franklin
benjamin franklin et la tribune il a dit
et c'est gravé sous le banc c'est
quasiment une des premières choses que
j'ai vu en arrivant là bas à
l'université de pennsylvanie
c'est cette phrase que vous retrouver
partout maintenant sur internet c'est et
qu'on est obligé de citer
monsieur le président de l'ue mais au
dans un amphi comme celui là qui
concerne l'enseignement qui est tu me
dis j'oublie tu mentionnes je me
souviens est humain implique j'apprends
le seul moment je me suis peut-être
impliqué dans ma formation c'est à dire
que je me suis dit je prends mon destin
en main je vais essayer deux alors
c'était peut-être pas conscient je le
raconte maintenant parce que j'ai 50 ans
les cheveux blancs je me rapproche de la
casse 3 mais je me suis dit allez
prenons le destin en main donc pendant
la première partie du parcours j'avais
appris ça j'avais appris à devenir
chirurgien à devenir chirurgien
orthopédiste
bon il ya pire dans la vie ma maman
était contente en tout cas je l'aï vu à
monsieur pensionnés sauf que le
chirurgien orthopédiste
en gros j'ai tapé sur google chirurgien
orthopédiste idiot abrutis et puis
schéma quoi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
j'ai trouvé des photos de gens
donc avant de consulter fait ça pour
être sûr de ne pas vous retrouver en
face d'eux mais bon à philadelphie on
m'avait dit athée chirurgien
orthopédiste c'est bien si tu restes aux
états unis tu vas pouvoir te faire décès
en or ils m'ont pas gardé et il m'avait
appris aussi la caricature de chirurgien
orthopédiste c'est le dossier du patient
c'est bonne broken me fixe ou un terminé
donc quatre mots de vocabulaire dans le
langage des orthopédistes et puis en
gros en france on a la réputation d'être
menuisier quand on n'est pas menuisier
on soigne les pieds donc l'orthopédie
pour information c'est en gros tout
l'appareil locomoteur donc les pieds la
tête le cou à tous où tout sauf la tête
peut-être d'accord donc avec ce métier
j'étais un truc pas mal mais je voulais
faire plus en fait il s'est avéré comme
on dit chez ibm que je suis tombé sur
des opportunités je vous racontais
l'histoire d' ibm après mais j'ai
découvert et la maman était moins
contente que peut-être fallait que je
fasse mon coming out est passé de la
case gauche à celle de droite selon
comment vous regarder l'écran vous
faites dans l'autre sens mais en gros
d'un homme à un geek
effectivement pendant ce par quoi
j'étais tombé dans la soupe
ce qui avait rendu mes parents heureux
quand j'étais devenu orthopédiste qu'ils
avaient plus à me subventionné mais
disquette qui allait coûter coûté à
l'époque coûter 10 francs les 300 medic
des 300 ko que je les aurai embêter
toute ma vie pour me payer mon premier
ordinateur qui était à nice 500 la ftf
et qu'après les autres ordinateurs je me
les suis acheté tout seul donc c'est là
où ils étaient contents mais bon il a
bien fallu que je fasse mon coming out
et puis là il ya un copain qui m'a
acheté ce tee shirt d'un jour et là je
me suis dit mince la situation est grave
je veux un tee shirt comme ça où je joue
je voyais bien que bon j'étais encore à
peu près au stade du milieu mais que
j'allais mal finir et je me suis dit
essayons finalement de mélanger ses
compétences acquises à l'école en
chirurgie orthopédique avec un espèce de
truc qui était dans mes chromosomes qui
était une sensibilité particulière à
l'informatique et j'ai eu une
opportunité c'est qu'à cette époque-là
se développer
commencé à apparaître en france il y
avait des gens qui cherchaient des gens
à compétence mix comme ça pour essayer
de faire des outils qu'ils allaient
rassurer un peu les chirurgiens parce
que l'image qu'on avait à cette époque
là et dans tous les congrès où j'allais
c'était cela qu'on me présentais c'était
le robot qui prenait la place de
chirurgiens qui opérait qui forcément se
planter c'est ça devait être windows xp
à l'époque mais avec windows dit ça
plante aussi à l'aréna qu'on fait des
mcsa plante aussi des entreprises aussi
qu'on fait ça donc rien qui marche en
fait et donc je me suis dit ben allons-y
mélangeant ses compétences
et puis essayons de faire naître
participer je me suis retrouvé embarqué
dans un mouvement qu'il a débuté au
début des années 2000 et je me suis dit
essayons de faire en sorte que les
orthopédistes arrête de penser que les
chiffres vont les remplacer un vieux
reste plus que cinq minutes vous êtes
mal voire pas voir la fin est passé de
l'autre côté du darkness profité d'une
opportunité alors j'ai pas parti sur
l'année la station apollo j'ai profité
d'une opportunité c'est que les gens qui
ont développé les stations apollo et les
véhicules lunaires ils ont utilisé des
technologies de localisation dans
l'espace qu'on a dérivé la communauté au
sens large au niveau international pour
se localiser dans le bloc opératoire est
donc en fait je me suis lancé dans un
grand domaine du traitement de
l'information appliquées à la charger de
paix dit que ce n'est pas forcément une
évidence au départ et c'est ça que je
vais essayer de vous raconter dans les
quatre minutes qui me reste
lorsqu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est
comme vous êtes tous malades un jour
pour savoir que 90 % de la population
passe un jour chez le chirurgien
orthopédiste pas parce qu'il est tombé
du bus soit parce qu'il est tombé du 4e
étage soit parce que
il a juste de l'arthrose il faut savoir
qu'on va vous faire à tout le monde tous
dans cette pièce la même chirurgie basée
sur des études d'antériorité mais quand
gros à tout le monde on va mettre la
prothèse de hanche dans la même position
or vous n'êtes pas sans savoir on en
entend parler tous les jours qu'on est
tous génomique mondes différents et que
si le génome est différent alors les
protéines qui sont codées par le jeune
home sont différentes les tissus et les
cellules pardon construite par ces
protéines sont différentes
donc les tissus sont différents donc les
organes sont différents et si je me suis
pas trompé les articulations sont
différentes
je n'ai pas oublié de clics donc on est
tous différent du génome donc duo
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment grand
mais vous pouvez reprendre le truc dans
l'autre sens et on fait la chirurgie là
même à tout le monde donc c'est un truc
qui va pas quelque part on n'a pas tous
les mêmes capacités fonctionnelles je me
définis d'essayer ce soir et puis avant
d'arriver à la casse 3 on passe par la
case 1
vous voyez qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
capacités fonctionnelles que là ce soir
si j'essaye de prendre mon biberon là ça
va pas le faire et que en vieillissant
bah on n'a pas non plus les mêmes
capacités fonctionnelles
ça veut dire que finalement il faut
comme on l'entend dire dans la
cancérologie où on va adapter les
traitements à aux marqueurs diot moreau
issus du génome humain dans la chirurgie
orthopédique faut faire pareil il faut
faire du traitement personnalisé et pour
faire du traitement personnalisé faut
avoir des mesures alors je vais vous
montrer sa macroscopiquement dans des
applications pour que vous partiez pas
que avec de la théorie une prothèse de
hanche chez sas et deux petits éléments
un convoi mettre dans le fémur puis un
autre parce que vous apercevez quand ça
tourne qu'on met dans le bassin qui est
le quilleuc utile et ça marche bien en
fait les amplitudes articulaires vont
être maximum si l'orientation des pièces
relativement l'une à l'autre sont bien
organisés donc le jeu ça consiste voilà
vous avez raté le décapsuleur le jeu ça
consiste non pas à boire une bière mais
à orienter le cot il par rapport à l'eau
c'est à dire la pièce de prothèses par
rapport à la hausse de façon optimale le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui tout est
pensé en statique et que quand vous vous
mettez debout assis ou couché
vous avez qu'à essayer ce soir vous
verrez que le rapport entre le bassin et
le fémur change sans arrêt donc non
seulement il faut penser en 3d il faut
penser les spécifications et il faut
penser non pas en 3d mais en 4d c'est à
dire en dynamique
si on va au bout du raisonnement qu'on a
mal monté la prothèse eh bien on va
avoir un premier mouvement si vous
prenez le décapsuleur chez vous ce soir
du mouvement des boîtes et on boit la
bière ça c'est le bon moment quand on
est impatient l'amplitude de sa prothèse
ça se déboîte s'appelle une luxation et
là ça fait très mal
donc c'est pas la bière du tout à ce
stade là d'accord donc pour essayer de
répondre à cette question il ya des gens
qui ont développé des systèmes et on en
n'a pas reconduit à participer utilisant
de l'imagerie radiographiques comme
celle que vous pouvez voir sur la vidéo
qui est un système non plus de
projections conique mais d'image qui
balaye de haut en bas qui vous fait en
3d vous allez le voir dans quelques
secondes
une reconstruction complète du squelette
et à partir de ces informations de
surface on va être capable de calculer
des angles plein tout ce qu'on veut des
angles des distances et puis on fait ça
si on fait ça de boer fessia pas couché
parce que la machine ne le permet pas
mais on fait ça accroupi et puis on
essaye de trouver une dynamique
pelvienne sauf que ça ça coûte 500 mille
euros l'appareil qui en a une petite
dizaine en france
donc si on veut permettre à tout le
monde de d'accéder à ces techno on
utilise quelque chose que vous
connaissez tous avaient tous eu un petit
frère ou une petite soeur
on vous sait revenir je l'espère pour
vous et on utilise l'échographie les
mêmes que les gynécologues ou presque et
on mesure la position du bassin en
mesurant 3 points assis debout couché et
ensuite on va être capable en utilisant
ces données d'entrée mesurer avec des
systèmes déco graphique d'utiliser la
techno apollo c'est à dire la
localisation dans l'espace deux
marqueurs infrarouge pour aller
positionner notre un plan de façon
dynamique en prenant en compte la
fameuse dynamique qui est propre aux
patients que pour la mesure et surtout
les gens du laboratoire on s'aperçut
comme on en avait tous une différente
donc c'est bien la chirurgie spécifique
passion
une autre petite histoire on a vu et
hausse
on a vu l'échographie les beatles qu'est
ce qu'il vient de là-dedans ils
sont morts même avant le break site les
beatles faut savoir que les beatles
alors via le pognon qu'ils ont généré
ont favorisé le développement du scanner
alors le scanner c'est le truc qu'on a
quand on a le cancer
c'est pierre desproges banque au scanner
noël au cimetière ce truc qu'on n'a pas
quand on voit un enfant et c'est le truc
qu'on n'a pas quand on est en bonne
santé mais le scanner c'est super utile
en imagerie médicale est en fait c y et
mick a développé le premier scanner ou
email pour par les anglo saxons et émail
c'était la boîte qui produisait les
beatles à l'époque et les royalties des
beatles ont permis de financer le
développement de la recherche ça c'est
pour la petite histoire sur le scanner
et puis on a utilisé une technologie
on peut fort
une technologie qui voyait peut changer
la face du monde qui s'appelle le
morphing
vous avez tout changer votre grand-mère
agit sur un jour où votre copine en
chemin ou un chien et nous on a utilisé
cette techno de façon utile pour
remplacer le scanner qui écoutent encore
trois cent mille euros par ce qu'on
appelle le bol morphing lorsque vous
voyez sur la vidéo d'en haut c'est un
modèle statistique d'un fémur qu'on voit
sur un écran pendant qu'on opère et on
promène sur l'os du patient alors là le
patient il est un peu ce que l'éthique
c'est un os en plastique mais on le fait
exactement pareil au bloc opératoire on
promène un stylet sur la surface de
l'eau c'est on enregistre la position
des points dans l'espace au fur et à
mesure avant hertz est ce que vous voyez
derrière voyez c'est un nuage de points
qui ressemble à un petit peu au modèle
qui est derrière et quand on a fait en
gros l'acquisition de 1000 points
on va déformer ce modèle statistique
pour venir se fusionner au nuage de
points ce qui fait qu'à la fin en une
minute trente vous avez l'anatomie du
patient que vous voulez opéré de façon
ultra-précise ultra précises pour nous
chirurgien c'est de l'ordre du
millimètre voilà la déformation vous
voyez les temps réel donc ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle le bonhomme morphing c'est
l'acquisition pour trois francs six sous
de la forme de vos structures osseuses
au bloc opératoire et ça nous donne un
modèle qui est la représentation très
exact de l'anatomie de vous de moi quand
on est à la phase 2 et on se rapproche
de la fin gentiment faut juste que
j'aille lancer mes vidéos
une fois qu'on a fait ces modèles
il va falloir qu'on puisse guider des
outils donc ces outils de repérage dans
l'espace nous servent à nous repérer
dans le bloc opératoire
je résiste pas vous montrer la première
vidéo de chirurgie orthopédique de la
hanche robotisée en france c'était aux
alentours de 2000 à peu près avec vous
allez le voir un robot qui est tout sauf
on va dire ergonomique
c'est un robot je t'oublie c'est pour
ceux qui réservent aux tic c'est un
robot qui sert à peindre des voitures il
a été transformé pour en faire un robot
médical
vous voyez qu'il est plus grand que
l'opérateur plus grand que le charge
qu'il est lourd et que ces robots il va
nous servir 20 minutes pendant
l'intervention il va nous coûter
alors on va dire parler en euros parce
qu'ils osaient de jeunes 1300 euros par
intervention et à la chasse est un truc
comme c'était 3 millions de francs après
je vous laisse convertir donc ce petit
robot
il faut lui apprendre ou et le patient
donc on est obligé de mettre des petits
marqueurs dans le patient finalement on
va amener le petit outil et puis
évidemment le robot il fraises mais si
le patient il s'en va pendant qu'il
ferait s'il va friser à côté en gros
s'il bouge sur la table ça va rater donc
on est obligé de cadenasser le patient
sur la table c'est ce qu'on faisait à
l'époque vous avez vu avec la grosse
tiges de fer et puis on a alors c'est le
moment là où il faut partir pour les se
compare à ses prix de pizzas et ce robot
ensuite porte une fraise au bout et va
friser la cavité je vais montrer pour
mettre une prothèse de hanche il faut
freiner une cavité dans le dans le fémur
à fraiser cette cavité avant qu'on
puisse mettre en place la prothèse alors
ça al'avantage de la précision et ça a
tellement d'inconvénients que en gros il
y en a eu deux commercialiser le premier
a été développée par ibm par un
vétérinaire pour des chiens et ensuite
quand ils ont commencé à tuer le chien
ils ont pas fait d'essais cliniques qui
l'envoyaient en europe pour qu'on le
pose sur des européens c'est leur hausse
dès le bon fonctionnement de la fds
donc ensuite en fraise voyez voilà et il
a il ya cette action de fraisage de la
cavité
alors ça marche bien c'est super précis
mais c'est tellement cher tellement
lourd tellement encombrants faut fixer
le patient sur la table tellement de
problèmes qu'on a développé des
alternatives dans nos laboratoires
français pour le coup et puis on les a
envoyés aux états unis pour servir sur
les américains la preuve
donc c'est un petit robot qui positionne
en fait un guide de coupe dans un plan
qui est planifié sur le modèle donc on
peut plus faire de bêtises il suffit de
rentrer la lame de scie dans le nord le
trou ou dans la fente je suis pas comme
vous c'est comme vous voulez donc il
faut faire cinq coupes pour mettre une
prothèse de genou et donc le robot peut
il bien se positionner en face des cinq
coupes alors comme le chirurgien
orthopédiste et feignant et qu'il avait
encore la coupe à faire on a développé
un système de freinage c'est ce que vous
avez en bas c'est le même c'est fini je
vais vouloir faire quand même
il n'y a pas eu de mort alors c'est bien
vous êtes des durs alors s'il veut bien
je lance juste la dernière qui fait
encore du bruit voyez que ça peut
devenir worth est donc ici on a une
fraise au lieu d'avoir une lame de scie
je rentre pas dans le détail de la vente
âge mais vous voyez que ce robot par
rapport au premier il est gros comme au
micro il pèse 1 kg on le met sur l'os
c'est à dax il aux bougies ben c'est pas
très grave le robot va suivre il n'y
aura pas de besoin de fixer le patient
et sa maintenance était tellement
intéressant que ça a été racheté par une
société américaine c'est l'histoire de
la technologie française et on l'a
jamais revu c'est à dire que moi je peux
pas l'utiliser en france alors qu'on l'a
développée tout simplement parce que la
prothèse qui est posée avec ce robot
n'est pas commercialisé ou diffusés en
tout cas en france
les en espagne mais il faudrait que je
passe la frontière la nuit et donc comme
j'ai énormément de retard et que c'était
prévu comme ça je vais m'arrêter là
une toute dernière de 30 secondes pour
vous montrer où on va dans le futur
c'est à dire qu'on miniaturise encore le
robot
ici on a une petite fraise et cette
petite phrase et se rétracte dans une
chemise de protection quand on arrive à
l'endroit où il faut plus fraiser donc
c'est un outil sécurisé vous allez voir
quand il va retirer l'outil un moment
tox la fraise disparaît d'accord un peu
plus à l'est fraiser au delà d'un espace
de sécurité
voilà en gros comment deux fois le temps
qu'il mettait à louer je suis capable de
vous raconter un petit peu l'histoire de
ce grand cheikh finalement et puis vous
voyez que ça ça peut se faire à brest
puisque ça se fait en gros dans un
laboratoire qui est juste de l'autre
côté de la rue qui s'appelle laboratoire
traitement de l'information médicale que
je dirige depuis quelques années
maintenant 2012 pour être précis et donc
pour finir à la parabole complète en
gros je suis prof d'informatique
médicale chirurgien orthopédiste et on a
fondé avec les copains du labo et les
doctorants donc l'avenir est ouvert pour
tous les jeunes aujourd'hui 5 start up
dont deux sur leur taupe et 10 dont une
devant dans 22 pays dans le monde des
effets déjà un million de chiffre
d'affaires donc et que en partant de
tout petits et de rien en passant par
david bowie l'espace on peut arriver
juste en face et faire plein de choses
sympas je vous remercie beaucoup